girl on my show the one who I was like
okay this is I'm gonna tell you this
story okay I'm sorry I'm all over the
place she may get the names away
and she okay I did we're talking a show
about body count right how many bodies
is too many body with it questions like
that I don't usually the only time I ask
people their body count is when I say is
body kind of important and they say no
and then I say then what's your body
count but the point isn't to get their
body count the point is to show it's
important right because otherwise
everyone would just be like this you
know so
um on this show as a joke I was like
what's your guys's body count I said ha
ha you don't have to say it's okay like
I was kidding she's all this Pro sex
girl so she's like oh I'll say it to get
rid of the stigma are you sure she says
yes okay go ahead go ahead this girl
threatens to sue me because she said her
body count on live
that's ridiculous why did you say yeah